[Music]
Steve Varley Steve Varley show okay
everybody I'm so excited today because I
am joined by Josh Sebastian and will who
star in Daisy and the jump Daisy Jones
and the six on Prime video how you guys
doing today great how's it going what's
up I'm doing great absolutely love the
show I'm excited to talk to you guys
um Josh with older Eddie tell me how did
it feel to rock that badass goatee and
did you want to keep that thing forever
but uh being clean shave for some reason
I'm one of those guys that I you know
every time my facial hair grows I'll
shave everything off and it I kind of go
down the line of going okay first goatee
and I'll shave down to mustache and I do
all of the iterations of different
facial hair in every single one I feel
stupid and then they end up cliching
every time so well dude you look great
either way and I like both and I love it
as for the older ready I think it just
totally works
um Sebastian do you think because you
drum in real life do you think drum
lessons are a necessity as they once
were or could you just learn drums from
something like rock band oh I don't know
I did play Rock Band when I was a kid
and I was smashing on the drums that was
definitely you're basically playing the
songs I think though the drum lessons
are important in terms of like having
good habits because like I knew that
there were certain things that I did
that were getting in the way if you're
trying to really like play to a higher
level and then you just get like it just
becomes easier to do the things that you
want to do yeah but a lot of it is just
like feeling it you know like if you
can't feel it in your body then you just
can't be a drummer you know no I 100 uh
agree with that and yeah it definitely
helps for sure and
um will did you ever imagine that your
guitar playing in real life would come
into play for an acting role is that
like crazy to you it kind of came full
circle
um I mean it was certainly a dream that
that would happen and it was very
quickly realized which was so cool
um but I would definitely Echo what Seb
said about the the habits thing I mean
like I've never had any training in
playing guitar or anything like that so
this was an awesome way to focus and get
like some real tips that have advanced
my playing to where it would never be
without this show oh that's amazing to
hear that yeah and uh my last question
Josh you wrote music for an album you
said on Instagram on set during this
that's really crazy did you ever get
interrupted while you were thinking of
something great to have to go film oh
yeah absolutely it was uh kind of
constant but I mean we were saying on a
different uh question a couple minutes
ago about how like as soon as the camera
stopped rolling you know like I'd start
twiddling on my bass he'd stop picking
up the sticks and will it be on the
guitar and we all were just constantly
kind of playing
um and I was always just like making
little voice notes of like any cool bass
riff that kind of came along or kept
coming back because I was like it would
be fun to like take this moment and try
and make some songs out of it later and
stuff so
uh yeah but it was always it was either
the cut would come and I'd have to stop
doing that or I'd be in the middle of a
scene and then it'd be straight back to
that again anyways
I love that uh yeah I feel like that's
just a movie should be about that in its
own right that's really cool
um Everybody check out Josh Sebastian
and we'll crush it in Daisy Jones and
the six on Prime video now thank you
guys so much for joining me today we'll
talk to you in the future
thank you